so we're you kind of adventurous when
you were growing up or I wanted to be
Indiana Jones and I was younger but then
I also super shy and when you like
sporty no so what more geeky I was super
heat this is basically my audition for
Indian okay let's get into this now this
is mangrove swamp this is a start of it
it's actually pretty amazing ecosystem
because it's just so full of incredible
diverse wildlife a lot of crops by the
way you know further into this stuff but
this is to start of the mangrove and we
need to be going this way that's it
gonna happen yeah this is gonna be many
things fun it's not gonna be one of
those let's do it
oh this as a survivalist is good God
look at the size Rhino beetle grub
larvae look at that there's another one
you get that one out oh my gosh
good protein good snack this is as a
general rule rule grubs are edible they
have more protein pound-for-pound than
beef and they are plentiful in dark damp
places all over the world but it's
critical that they are purged before
consumption in case of eatin something
poisonous to humans they let grab the
head no and then you just twist the head
pull that off I think some really
medieval gut it out listen as many
things but there's not a hard I think
that's his anal tract for that and
that's all good good energy I'll surely
go first what would you want to go first
I don't think I got all the able track
down to flavor okay great
I just ate a beetle larva I'd rather not
explain say it's like yeah doesn't taste
very good
oh good energy feel energetic yeah I
think I'm supposed to feel more
energized than I do I think that
cappuccinos work better
[Music]